"A, B y C son puntos colineales y B se encuentra
entre A y C. La razón de AB a AC es 2:5. Si A está
en (-6,9) y B está en (-2,3), ¿cuáles son las
coordenadas del punto C?" Los invito a pausar
el video y tratar de resolverlo por su cuenta.
Intentemos visualizar esto: A está en (-6,9);
veamos, B está más hacia la derecha en la
dirección horizontal y está más abajo en la
dirección vertical, de modo que podríamos poner
AB justo aquí, B está en el punto (-2,3), y el
punto C va a ser colineal, así que vamos a seguir
la misma línea. Déjenme trazar esta recta ahora,
así que va a ser colineal, y nos dicen que la
razón de AB a AC es de 2:5, entonces B estará
a 2/5 del camino. Así que digamos que C es -estoy
dibujando a ojo-; pongamos el punto C aquí mismo,
y no conocemos las coordenadas del punto C.
Bueno, la forma en que podríamos pensar en esto
es calcular el cambio en la coordenada horizontal
y el cambio en la coordenada vertical y aplicar
la misma razón. Por ejemplo, ¿cuál es el cambio
en las coordenadas horizontales de A a B? Bueno,
dibujemos eso. Para ir de A a B tenemos la
coordenada x de A que es igual a -6 y la
coordenada x de B es igual a -2, así que este
es el cambio horizontal que nos interesa. Ahora
¿cuánto es eso? Bueno, si comenzamos en -6 y
pasamos a -2, tenemos un incremento de 4. Otra
forma de pensar en esto es -2 - -6, que es lo
mismo que -2 + 6 = 4. Ahora, la relación entre
este cambio y el cambio en la coordenada x entre
los puntos A y C va a ser de 2:5, así que llamemos
a este cambio, a todo este cambio, llamémosle x.
Entonces podríamos decir que la razón de 4 a x es
igual a, vemos que este es el cambio horizontal de
AB, que es igual a 4, el cambio horizontal entre A
y C tendrá que ser la misma razón, que es igual a
2/5. Ahora, para resolver x, algo divertido podría
ser simplemente tomar el recíproco de ambos lados,
entonces x / 4 = 5 / 2. Podemos multiplicar ambos
lados por 4 y nos queda que x = 5 • 4 / 2, que es
igual a 10, entonces el cambio en x de A a C es
igual a 10. ¿Qué nos dice eso sobre la coordenada
x de C? Podríamos comenzar con la coordinada
x de A, que es -6, y sumar 10, - 6 + 10 = 4. Ya
calculamos la coordenada x, ahora sólo tenemos que
hacer lo mismo con la coordenada y, entonces ¿cuál
es el cambio en y de ir de A a B? Bueno, aquí
vamos de 9 a 3, disminuimos 6. Otra forma en que
podríamos decirlo es 3 - 9 = -6, para encontrar
el cambio podríamos pensar que estamos tomando
el punto final y restándole el punto de partida:
-2 - -6 fue igual a 4 positivo, 3 - 9 = -6, o
simplemente puedes mirarlo. Hemos disminuido 6,
por lo que podemos escribir aquí -6. Ahora, para
nuestro cambio en y, vamos a tener la misma razón,
entonces a nuestro cambio en y entre A y C, que
es esta distancia, le llamaremos y, entonces este
es nuestro cambio en y, y vamos a tener la misma
razón, de modo que podríamos escribir que la razón
entre nuestro cambio en y, de A a B, que es -6 a
nuestro cambio en y de A a C -6 a y una vez más es
igual a 2:5. De nuevo podríamos tomar el recíproco
de ambos lados: y / -6 = 5 / 2, multiplicamos
ambos lados por -6, y nos queda que y = 5 • -6
= -30 / 2 = -15. Entonces nuestro cambio en y,
es decir, el cambio en nuestro eje vertical,
que en este caso llamamos y = -15, así que aquí,
si nuestro valor de y es 9 y le restamos 15, ¿a
dónde llegamos? Bueno, 9 - 15 = -6, entonces la
coordenada y para el punto C está en 9 - 15 = -6.
Entonces 4, -6 son las coordenadas del punto C.